madame monsieur bonjour une semaine
après l'horrible drame le meurtre du
petit grégoryi à l'épangeche sur Vologne
dans les vauges les enquêteurs n'ont
toujours pas retrouvé l'assassin mais
l'étau se resserre autour de lui car les
gendarmes sont surr maintenant qu'il est
un proche voire un membre de la famille
à l'intérieur de laquelle existe des
haines farouches qui ont pu pousser l'un
d'entre eux à ce crime odieux l'assassin
est donc aujourd'hui toujours libre et
sûrement se trouve itil samedi dernier
présent aux obsèes du petit garçon
Jean-Claude
darigot la police en est convaincu
l'assassin se trouve parmi ses hommes et
ses femmes ces hommes et ces femmes qui
ont participé à l'enterrement du petit
Grégorie chaque visage des membres de la
famille de l'enfant a été scruté par les
enquêteurs pour déceler un comportement
une attitude insolite résultat rien de
décisif pour le moment de toute façon C
cette famille ce groupe humain de 70
personnes fait bloc bloc contre les
questions bloc contre la vérité la loi
du silence fonctionne comme chez les
gangsters et les
voyou les traces de chaussures et de
pneus sur les lieux du crime n'ont pas
été éloquente non plus quant à l'examen
graphologique de l'écriture des suspects
ses conclusions sont pour le moment
gardées secrètes par les policiers une
chose est certaine personne n'a été
inculpé personne n'est encore ement
accusé du meurtre d'un enfant de 4 ans
et demi mort noyé comme un petit chat
dans une rivière des vauges l'enfant on
le sait mieux aujourd'hui a été la
victime de jalousie familiale son père a
commis semble-t-il le crime de mieux
réussir que d'autres membres de sa
famille et cela a suscité la folie de
l'assassinat chez là où les personnes
qui ont exécuté grégoryi on se souvient
de l'affaire Dominici où tout un groupe
humain avait fait obstacle à la justice
on entend cha par de la mafia et de
l'omerta la règle de la nonpole dans les
vuges sans mafia un bambin est mort
assassiné et c'est quand même le
silence